oh mein Gott das Messer ist gebrochen aha
eine Zeit mit der ich sehr zufrieden
bin und ich glaube dass das alles
wirklich dazu geführt hat dass ich so früh
abgebrochen habe ich bin richtig glücklich
ich will gar nicht daran
denken was noch alles kommt
ausgesetzt in der Wildnis von Schweden kämpft
ein Mann sieben Tage mit sieben Gegenständen
ums Überleben ich bin wieder da der erste Versuch
endete für den outdoor-neuling schnell bei uns zu
mir ehrlich übelst live Sport und Helme waren
ihm dadurch sicher doch jetzt ist er zurück an
dem Ort an dem alles begann die Wiedergutmachung
keine Kamera Teams Jetzt Geht's Ab kein Kontakt
zur Außenwelt raste aus Mann vollkommene
Isolation herzlich Willkommen zu gay seven
ich habe diesen zwei Versuch so unendlich
lang vor mir hergeschoben weil ich immer
gedacht habe es wäre nicht die richtige Zeit
es würde mir irgendwas fehlen und eigentlich
hätte ich jederzeit starten können und genauso
ist es mit all den kreativen guten Ideen die
bei euch in den Köpfen rumspielen ihr müsst
einfach nur starten und genau deswegen bin
ich unheimlich stolz das shopify das heutige
Video als Partner unterstützt shopify ist die
perfekte all in one-lösung um ohne irgendwelche
Programmierkenntnisse und vorher Erfahrung ein
eigenes Business zu starten und das meine ich
wenn ich sage denn ich habe schon einige Male
hier auf Youtube unter Beweis gestellt nicht nur
ist es durch den website editor unfassbar leicht
einen Job aufzuziehen nein man kann auch Dich live
Analytics und Statistiken von den Kunden lernen
und so mehr verkauft ich würde sogar soweit gehen
dass ohne shopify die komplette trader-serie gar
nicht möglich gewesen wäre mein eigener klamotten
online shop die Golfbälle die ich euch verschenkt
habe Porsche Modelle und der Print on Demand Shop
laufen und liefen alle über shoppy feiern und auch
ohne dass ihr es wisst seid ihr tagtäglich
in Shops unterwegs eure lieblings Brands und
auch meine lieblings Brands nutzen nämlich zu
großen Teilen das Ding ist ein Shop aufzuziehen
lässt sich online kreativ auszuleben war noch nie
so einfach wie es also klickt auf den ersten Link
in der Videobeschreibung und gebt euren Träumen
eine Chance ihr habt ehrlich nichts zu verlieren
und dieses Tool ist der Oberhammer das sage ich
aus voller Überzeugung und als kleines Dankeschön
weil ihr diese Serie so krass supportet und weil
ich Lust hatte noch mal einen Job zu bauen gibt es
in diesem Video wieder ein verstecktes Passwort
zu einem Shop der auch in der Videobeschreibung
verlinkt ist findet das Passwort tragt es ein und
sichert euch eins der kostenlosen Produkte seid
schnell die Artikel sind begrenzt und jetzt viel
Spaß mit der dritten Folge meines Selbstversuchs
herzlich willkommen am Tag
4 es geht genauso weiter wie
die letzten Tage Wind und Regen
ich bleibe liegen bis durch ist
fick mich guten Morgen liebe Sorgen das
Ding hält besser als gedacht und auch
heute Nacht hat es wieder geregnet
aber das hier wirkt alles ziemlich
trocken geil alles in bester Ordnung und
wir starten sofort mit Challenge für Tag
viel ich weiß natürlich alles was kommt aber
ich weiß nicht in welcher Reihenfolge jetzt
heute einen Floß bauen muss mir Insekten
in den Mund stopfe was hier Sache ist
fire Baby deine Aufgabe mach ein Feuer mit Hilfe
eines feuerbohrers das kann ja was werden dafür
kannst du dir einen Bogen bauen oder deine Hände
benutzen das Feuer muss einzig und alleine vom
Feuerbohrer stammen schaffst du es ein Feuer mit
mindestens eine Minute Brenndauer zu entfachen
erhältst du dieses gesamten 7 Punkte Filme die
Minute zu Verifizierung du hast Zeit bis die Sonne
untergeht ach du scheiße folgender Plan feuerborn
ist unheimlich schwierig das weiß ich weil Fritz
damit seit Jahren immer wieder kämpft im Nassen
Gebieten und so weiter der hat das hinbekommen
aber fritz ist jemand der jahrelange Erfahrung
hat und die habe ich nicht das bedeutet ich muss
mir möglichst gute Vorarbeit leisten bedeutet so
viel wie ich mache mir ein Feuer normal mit meinem
Feuerzeug an und trockene am Feuer das gesamte
Holz dass ich benutzen will komplett durch nicht
so das brennt aber einfach das ist komplett
furztrocken ist und probiere es dann damit so
glaube ich kann ich die einzige Möglichkeit wie
ich irgendeine Chance habe glücklicherweise habe
ich ja noch paracordt damit kann ich mir den Bogen
spannen und mit dem Messer kriege ich auch noch
Holz gespalten und ich glaube genau damit fangen
wir an brauchen irgendwas was wahrscheinlich
echt nicht auf dem Boden liegt sondern ein
bisschen vom Boden weg so was hier in der Sonne
das wirkt auch feucht das ist auch nichts ist auch
noch viel zu schwer ich weiß um ehrlich zu sein
halt auch nicht wie man das perfekte Holz findet
vielleicht da vorne sowas das sieht aus als wäre
ja okay das wäre es wirklich weit vom Boden weg
ja das hier wirkt schon trockener ich glaube
hier von säge ich mir mal ein Stückchen ab
ja ich komme aus dem Bett denke ich habe mega
Power nicht eine Sekunde irgendwas
und merke ich überhaupt keine Kraft
der könnte trocken sein aber lieber
nicht ein Pilz warum Pilz komplett
nass das ist auch komplett nass keine Ahnung Alter
nee das ist komplett nass
oder soll ich das wirklich wagen dieses Ding
ich meine da oben wird das doch furztrocken
sein oder ich fange mal langsam an zu sägen und
zwar will ich den am liebsten in die Richtung
hauen das bedeutet ich will den da Sägen
so so sieht das aus wenn man nicht aus den
Fehlern anderer lernt und ich hoffe jetzt
einfach dass nichts runter kommt [Musik]
ist noch nicht
ich glaube das ist gut
schön weghalten von mir
noch einmal zurückschwingen lassen
jetzt volle Kraft voraus [Applaus]
geil sowas in trocken ist doch
perfekte Auflagefläche Alter ich kann
mir eine Regenrinne bauen hier mit
ich war einfach eine Regenrinne das
hier sieht aus wie der perfekte Boden
von baugrill oh nee das sind
irgendwelche Eier schnell weg
es ist nur die Frage wie kriege ich das darüber
ich glaube ich schneide das
immer so zwei Meter Stücke
essen oder so
ja ich muss gleich einmal eine
vernünftige Ladung sammeln
oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott wie so ein Dulli und die
ganzen Sägespäne gehen verloren und
nachher probiere ich irgendwie händeringend
an Sägespäne zu kommen und dann kriegst nicht
hin deswegen sage ich Dir jetzt
direkt hier in meine Regenrinne
perfekt kommt gar nichts drin an
kann nicht mehr
jetzt fallen Sägespäne rein
perfekt
für die nächsten Tage
also um ganz ehrlich zu sein
ist heute so der richtig
oder das also ich bin die ganze Zeit ja einsam
und hier ist nichts und niemand weit und breit
aber heute bin ich wirklich wirklich
viel in Gedanken ich habe echt
kein Bock mehr die Phasen wo ich wirklich gehypt
bin werden immer kürzer ich merke dass ich immer
mehr einfach in der Hängematte rumsitze
nicht mal mehr die Kamera Anmache einfach
Zeit vergehen lassen und hoffe dass das hier
irgendwie zu einem Ende kommt und ich einfach
keinen Bock mehr auf die scheiß Isolation habe
ich keinen Bock mehr darauf hab hier zu sein
ich kann Bock mehr habe auf die Challenges
ich habe einfach keinen Bock mehr ich habe
keinen Bock mehr zu sägen ich habe keinen Bock
mehr ans Wasser zu laufen ohne Wasser zu holen
keinen Bock mehr auf die Mücken ich will
einfach nicht mehr ich will einfach nicht mehr
hier ist nicht ist nichts gar
nichts ist hier ich fühle mich
dreckig ich fühle mich räudig ich
habe Hunger ich habe keine Energie
es ist richtiger abfuck aber ich
bin quasi gezwungen
das jetzt dieses Mal durch zu machen wegen diesem
scheiß erst versucht hätte ich das dadurch gezogen
hätten müssen wir die ganze Scheiße hier nicht
mehr antun aber ein zweites Mal aufzugeben
ist eigentlich keine Option ich trage die
scheiße jetzt rüber machen wir ein Feuer an
trockne das Zeug und setzt mich ein bisschen
ans Feuer und hoffe dann wird es besser ich
mach die Kamera aus und sage dass ich keinen
Bock mehr habe und es fängt an zu nieseln
top komm weiter regnen super ist
genau was ich brauche für meine
Challenge es ist zum kotzen zum Kotzen zum kotzen
scheiß aber jetzt glaube ich
einfach durch den Regenjacke
habe ich eh gestern reingepackt wie so ein Idiot
jetzt regnet
meine Fresse Alter
das hier fuckt mich bis heute so krank ab was zum
Fick ist das ich will hier sieben Tage draußen nie
was machen und an Tag 2 geht diese Scheiße kaputt
ist unglaublich Alter und ich dachte ich kaufe
irgendein Qualitätsprodukts kompletter Müll guck
mal den hier habe ich gerade auf dem Weg gefunden
der ist nicht perfekt gerade aber dieses
Stück hier könnte schon passen als
dass das richtige Material ist aber das
nehme ich einfach mal mit schauen wir
mal ich muss das an der Klinge packen
sonst kann ich das nicht mehr benutzen
[Musik]
komplett nass
muss ich komplett trocknen das ist der
Grill keine Ahnung habe ich hier eine
Kerbe rein machen muss oder nicht werden wir
gleich sehen das brauche ich noch einen Bogen
und ich muss das Feuer anmachen bin
hier wirklich kleinteilig am vorbereiten
um immer nächst größere Stücke Holz
zu haben die jetzt gleich alle einzeln
noch getrocknet werden und dann überlasse
ich nichts dem Zufall ich habe Birkenrinde
getrocknet Späne gehobelt und dann die und
dann eben noch richtiges Holz oder größeres
das hier habe ich gerade eben
gefunden hier so eine Kerbe
wo mein Ast drin war und vielleicht
benutze ich das habe ich mir überlegt
[Applaus]
was richtig nach hart
drecksmesser Alter was für eine unglaubliche
scheiße ich habe die ganze Zeit geredet ohne
das lief ich mache jetzt erstmal ein normales
Feuerchen damit ich die ganzen anderen Sachen
hier schön Trocknen kann und dann geht die
Party ab so also der Baum an sich ist schon
mal Spitze das brennt wie Sau oh wunderbar
also beim Feuer wirklich ist die Vorarbeit
das A und O ich habe das hier so schön klein
gespalten und dann geht das mit ein bisschen Zeug
komplett lichterloh in Flammen auf so
und jetzt lege ich schon mal meine Sachen
daneben zum trocknen hier diese Kerbe die
ich gemacht habe Balken lege ich so hier hin
dann kann das schön durchtrocknen der
anderen Seite muss das hier auch dahin
mache ich mir hier einfach noch so ein und
da ist eigentlich nur die Seite wichtig
jetzt muss ich mir im Auge behalten
dass es auf keinen Fall reinfällt
ich lese mir den Zettel gleich noch mal durch
aber ich habe dem nicht entnehmen können dass
das jetzt nicht okay wäre schön trockenes Holz
braucht man dafür und ich sorge für trockenes Holz
man sieht richtig kommt ich hoffe
ihr seht das auch auf der Cam
kommt oder so raus
kommt wie hätte ich denn damit Feuer machen
sollen niemals boah ich glaube das ist ein
Geniestreich um ehrlich zu sein so das war jetzt
einmal komplett abgekuckt ich habe das jetzt
hier mühevoller kleinarbeiter wieder abgeschabt
damit ihr auch wieder Material ist das überhaupt
verkokeln kann und jetzt bauen wir alles zusammen
bauen noch einen Bogen und dann probieren wir es
einfach mal wenn ich das so nicht hinbekomme dann
gar nicht aber ich glaube der Weg ist gar nicht so
dumm ich habe einen Bogen und die ist richtig
Zug drauf unten habe ich keinen Knoten drin
ja wunderbar sondern das einfach so
tausendmal hier drum gewickelt weil
ich nicht weiß wie ich das sonst zu knoten soll
wir probieren es einfach mal aus erster Versuch
hier ist richtig Spannung drauf
ach du scheiße ich Rutsch komplett aus der Kerbe
ach nee ich glaube ich muss mir eine neue
Kerbe bauen so neues noch neuer Versuch
mein Gott
Alter das geht aber ab
Alter hier ist gar nichts das ist viel zu
nass das sieht einfach nur spiegelglatt
ist das falsche Holz es muss das falsche Holz
sein guck mal was hier für speeds mache Alter
das funktioniert es funktioniert [Musik]
[Musik]
kein bisschen Glut Alter habt ihr das gesehen
und ich sag noch es ist das falsche Holz
ich glaube es ist das falsche Holz aber
vielleicht haben wir so gut durchgetrocknet
dass wir es hinbekommen Alter oh mein Gott
kein bisschen Glut Alter
ich muss weiter durchziehen ach du scheiße das
wäre ja so geisteskrank oh meine Hände tun weh
scheiße
nein das Ding ist ich habe halt keinen so
richtiges Zumba Bett ne oh nein es fängt an
zu regnen oh nein oh nein oh nein oh mein Gott der
schlechteste Zeitpunkt es ist unglaublich wirklich
man hat ein Erfolgserlebnis und man wird dann
einfach wieder in den Boden gestampft oh mein Gott
es ist zum Mäuse melken bevor ich jetzt wirklich
weitermache suche ich mir mehr zundermaterial ich
habe das hier an diesem Bäumen gefunden ich
weiß nicht ob das wirklich brennt ich teste
das jetzt gleich erstmal mit dem Feuerzeug
aber hiermit könnte ich mir vielleicht so
ein richtiges Nest bauen ich habe zwar
gerade noch keine Gluten bekommen aber
es hat ja schon so gewirkt als wenn ich
das jetzt noch mal länger und weitermachen
würde dass das klappen könnte also hier raus
und Netz bauen und dann gucken ob das geht
kurzer Test mit dem Feuerzeug es
wirkt schon trocken aber es wirkt
irgendwie nicht so als wird das so krank brennen
oh doch doch okay perfekt das Zeug hier jetzt
geht's ab jetzt jetzt geht's ab wenn ich das
schaffe das wäre wirklich geisteskrank okay
okay okay okay so ich habe mir kurze Hand
ein neues Brett gebaut für oben oben ist ja eh
nicht so wichtig da muss muss sich nur drehen
mein gott ich hasse es rutscht ab meine Fresse
mein Gott in der Ruhe liegt die Kraft
ich flippe aus alter ich war so nah dran
gerade eben was für eine scheiße ich gebe
dem jetzt wirklich noch ein bisschen
mehr Seil oh was für eine Pizza Alter
weil ich einfach mal auf schnell auf
hektisch vielleicht ist das so rein um
das da rein hilft nicht Müll
so eine Pizza Alter es warum
kriege ich das jetzt nicht mehr hin
ich raste aus alter ich raste aus was
für eine was für ein räudiger Müll es
ist unglaublich dieser Müll dieser unglaubliche
Müll ich flippe wirklich gleich komplett aus
es ist zu Hause jetzt ist es
zu Hause jetzt ist es zu Hause
es wäre so krank wenn ich das hinbekommen
würde erstes Mal in meinem Leben dass
ich machen würde das allererste Mal
ich
werde verrückt
ich raste aus Mann
wie konnte da gerade eben kein einziger
verfickter Funke sein jetzt habe ich hier
den übelsten Zunder und jetzt kriege ich
das Ding nicht eine Umdrehung mehr gedreht
nein
nein hey ich lasse es sein ich lasse es
ich pack die Sachen wieder weg reg mich
kurz ab und ich werde das versuchen bis
in den Sonnenuntergang aber es geht nicht
so es ist soweit ich bin ich bin komplett
abgenervt ich laufe jetzt eine Runde einmal
komplett um den Teich und guck ob ich irgendwas
finden kann was mir hilft eine Flasche werde
absolute Traum das ist nicht immer wieder
mein Kopf da ins Wasser stecken muss um ein
paar Schlücke zu trinken und auch mal Wasser mit
ins Camp nehmen kann weil jetzt gerade laufe ich
immer darüber trink trink trink trink trink
dann mache ich irgendwas geh zurück ins Camp
streng mich nur ein bisschen an und dann muss ich
wieder darüber laufen ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass hier vorne was angespielt wird weil das
werdet ihr gleich sehen die Wellen kommen
immer genau aus der Richtung oder vielleicht
ganz vorne auf der Zunge wo ich in Staffel 1
ausgesetzt wurde da war beim letzten Mal
ja auch schon wie so ein Feuerplatz von
irgendwelchen Kanuten oder so die alle
sieben Pfingsten mal hier vorbeikommen
und hoffentlich sind die wenig umweltbewusst und
haben vielleicht irgendwas liegen lassen oder so
seht ihr die Welt kommen immer hier so an
also im Zweifelsfall wird hier
irgendwann irgendwas angespült
ja und jetzt heißt es suchen schon schön
wirklich schön würde ich meinen Camp
noch mal bauen würde ich wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen näher ans Wasser bauen
hier ist nichts Federn Federn also wenn
ich wirklich irgendwas mit Federn bauen
will dann gibt sie hier genug
nichts gar nichts da ist was
irgendeine
aber kein Haken oder soll es ja keine
kein fischergarden keine Angelschnur
aber das wäre es natürlich
hier wären die Barsche wenn ich mich
recht entsinne guck mal hier ist
auch wieder überall scheiße was ist
das wohl ist das für ein Tier Alter
guck mal hier ist überall Kacke gar nichts
ist hier hier ist Müll den nehme ich mit
sogar frisch das mindest Haltbarkeitsdatum 31.10
20 23 oh was würde ich für so ein bisschen
Angelschnur und einen Haken geben Alter
ja herzlich willkommen soweit ich mich
erinnern kann an meinem ersten Spot
hier ist der Draht den ich damals
gefunden habe nehme ich auf jeden Fall mit
weil sie aber nicht wofür ich den gebrauchen
könnte aber die hier sind doch nicht von mir
oder die habe ich doch niemals um gemacht nach
zwei Jahren würden die doch nicht so aussehen oder
nee es kann eigentlich nicht sein aber ich
glaube trotzdem dass das hier der Spot war
krass komplett offen ihr merkt man auch wie
viel Wind hier durchkommt Hammer dumm na ja
und es kommt Pilze
aber noch keinen einzigen großen
gesehen wie schön sieht das aus
richtig krass
ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock mehr Tag 4 dann
Nachmittag ich habe das mit dem Feuer versucht
ich kriege es nicht hin es nervt mich ab ich
versuche es wieder es klappt nicht versucht es
wieder es klappt nicht ich versuche jetzt gleich
noch mal aber abseits davon hat man so unendlich
viel Zeit das ist wirklich unglaublich wie viel
Zeit man hat ich sitze hier rum und Stahl Löcher
in die Luft ich habe jetzt hier alles gemacht
ich habe angefangen die Stöcke an dem Baum zu
zählen ich habe also nachgedacht und nachgedacht
über tausende Dinge aber ich es fühlt sich an
als hätte ich genug nachgedacht ich will nicht
mehr nur mit mir alleine sein ich will wieder
mit Leuten reden ich will Reaktionen auf irgendwas
bekommen das ist der absolute Horror wirklich das
ist ich kann mir gerade jetzt im Moment nichts
schlimmeres vorstellen ich habe einfach keinen
Bock mehr und ich will dass es vorbei geht hätte
ich jetzt noch mal die Wahl hätte ich garantiert
ein angelset mitgenommen dann hätte man sich
hinstellen können und hätte warten können aber
im Zweifelsfall wäre irgendwann irgendwas passiert
das ist so ein nicht grundloses warten und man
kann jetzt auch nicht anfangen hier joggen zu
gehen oder Bahn zu schwimmen oder irgendwas zu
machen weil man die Energie dazu nicht hat das ist
echt richtige Größe Scheiße vor dem Herrn wirklich
und mir geht's ja noch gut ich habe meinen Tag
ich habe meine Hängematte ich habe
meinen Schlafsack mir ist nicht kalt
aber es ist fucking langweilig
so noch mal ich sage es euch das wird jetzt das
letzte Mal sein dass ich diese Scheiße Versuche
von letzte Mal
ich warum springe ich mache
jetzt hier eine coole rein
es geht kaputt mehr ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
so ich habe mich jetzt erzählt ein kleines
Feuer zu machen mit dem einzigen Sinn und
Zweck die Überbleibsel dieser drecks Challenge
loszuwerden und jetzt verbrenne ich alles davon
weil anders hat die ganze Scheiße das
nicht verdient ich hasse es ich hasse
diesen Tag das war der beschissenste Tag den
ich bisher gehabt hatte ich weiß nicht mehr
was ich machen soll Alter es nervt mich nur
noch ab ich es ist wirklich zum Heulen von
außen wirkt das vielleicht so ein bisschen
lächerlich aber ich will wirklich einfach
losfliehen dass mich ab nervt weil
es Pisse ist und weil ich das hasse
guck mal das hätte wäre ein Funke
gewesen ein Funke und das Ding
brennt lichterloh es hätte so einfach
sein können aber wir schließen ab damit
so jedes Stück einzeln hier dieses scheiß Ding der
Scheiß Bora geh in Flammen auf du Stück Scheiße
[Musik]
ich gehe mir jetzt mal meinen Abendbrot zusammen
suchen erstaunlicherweise gibt es Blaubeeren
in der Staffel 1 schon tausendmal gesehen
und schaut euch das an die sind die Verein
ich habe halt nach wie vor keinen Behältnis
das bedeutet ich sammeln die immer in meiner
Hand ist so eine halbe Hand voll ab und
dann mache ich einen großen wissen 1 2 3
so aber erstaunlicherweise geht
mir das nicht auf den Sack also
der Geschmack ich glaube es liegt daran dass
ich einfach Hunger habe und egal was nehme
so und mit leichtem Regen und wieder in der
Hängematte endet Tag Nummer 4 und ich freue
mich riesig Augen zu Morgen aufwachen und
über dem Berg sein dann geht es nur noch
Richtung Ziel die sieben Tage und nach wie
vor ist mein Tab dicht alles ist wunderbar
und ich mache jetzt die
Äuglein zu Gute Nacht tschüss
aus ich bin ein Star aber Holt mich hier raus